doing your mom doing doing your mom doing your mom doing doing your mom doing to your mom
you know its straight doing your mom doing your mom doing your mom doing doing your mom
doing your mom doing doing your mom doing do too in your mom
Doing your mom, doing your mom, doing your mom, doing your mom, doing your mom
You know we're straight, doing your mom
I'm doing your mom, yes yours
first saw her in the Walmart
picking out your drawers
big dolly part in hair
like an 80s prom queen
the rest was looking good
all up in the mom jeans
I approached her in the checkout line
and said you know baby what's up
she had 2 gallons of milk
and I was staring at her jugs
5 minutes later she agreed to get with me
so we went and rocked the minivan
like giggity giggy giggy giggy
I was riding your mom
like she's my real car
I gave her a lift back to her crib
cause her car wouldn't start
she invited me in the house
and we started making out again
how many times I tapped that ass
over 9000
yeah she called me pledge
cause I knocked the dust off it
later made me a sandwich
and she cut the crust off it
cause she knows how I like it
and that I'm a little young
to be in the bed
but naked
doing your mom
doing doing your mom
you know we straight
doing your mom
doing doing your mom
you know we straight
doing your mom
I'm a big butt
and I can not lie
you know other brothers can't deny that she's fly
you make sexy on time
yes and every night I tap that
she told me but naked
now she thinks I'm half black
but your mom's the best
at super M I L
F
Cause she loves a toaster salad even though she ain't a chef
And I blame it on the alcohol
If I were you, I wouldn't kiss your mom on the mouth at all
She likes a donkey pun, she likes a dirty Sanchez
Sometimes she even likes to fool around in your bed
She likes rough sex with handcuffs and I'll be honest
She likes me to Chris Browner when she acts like Rihanna
She's so therapeutic when I need to cure my racistness
I brrrrrr
Murderboat your mom's racist
I didn't wanna tell you but I had to write the song
Cause I'm in your house every night
Doin' your mom, doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' doin
That makes me better for better than you
Doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom
You know we straight, doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' doin' your mom, doin' your mom, doin' normal
Doing, doing your mom, doing, doing your mom, doing, doing your mom
You know we straight, doing your mom